اود ان اقول واصحح انني لم استخدم مطلقا
طائره تابعه لبن علي نعم الوضع كان صعبا
وانا صرحت وقد اسيء تفسير تصريحاته في شكل
مشوه وخصوصا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
هذا هو الواقع وقتها كانت بدايه استخدام
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وتم تشويه
تصريحاته كما لو كنت انا من ادلى بها وهذا
غير صحيح هذه امور تحدث في السياسه وفي
صوره متزايده لسوء الحظ كما تعرفون هذا هو
الواقع هذا الامر تم تضخيمه من قبل البعض
هؤلاء لم يكونوا يريدون ان تكون لي شعبيه
كمرشحه لرئاسه الجمهوريه ولم نكن نعرف ما
اذا كان الرئيس ساقوزي سيترشح مجددا
للرئاسه وقتها كان اسمي مطروحا وكان هناك
اشخاص ربما لا يحبونني ارى دور فما تقود
سيرتي ولن اخذ اكثر في هذا المجال
وصراعات داخليه فرنسيه فرنسيه حزبيه وبين
سلطه ومعارضه همم لذلك يعني زادت حده هذه
الاتهامات
مع ضمن الغالبيه ذاتها
نقول شخصيات على اي حال هذا من الماضي
وعلينا ان نترك الماضي للماضي هناك الكثير
مما يجب ان نفعله في الحاضر ههه
وليس في الحاضر ولكن حتى موضوع العطله
تنفيها على حساب الرئيس حتى موضوع
التصريحات بالمساعده الامنيه للاحتجاجات
في تونس ايضا كان فينا ذلك للتاريخ
اما ارد ان تقول لي الاتهامات التي يحكى
عنها في العالم العربي بانك قضيت اجازه في
تونس مع عائلتك على حساب الرئيس بن علي
وهذا كان ماخذا عليك تحديدا
ولا اعتقد ان هذا الكلام سبق ان قيل من
قبل لا احد قال ان الرئيس التونسي الاسبق
دفع تكاليف رحلتك كنت اذهب مرارا في
الاعوام الفائته لتمضيه العطله في تونس
وقلت ذلك في صوره طبيعيه والرئيس بن علي
التقيته اربع مرات فقط طوال مسيره المهنيه
وفي عشاء رسمي في تونس او باريس اذا الامر
مختلف تماما مع ما يقال لم يكن هناك
علاقات خاصه معه عندما كنت وزيره كنتقي
بنظراء وباصدقاء تونسيه
نكون امام اجوبه حاسمه منك شخصيا كل
الاتهامات التي تملا وسائل التواصل
والانترنت في هذا الموضوع تحديدا كتبت
مقالا في الليموند بعد ذلك تقرين فيه بفشل
الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه في توقع او استشعار
ما سيحدث لاحقا في العالم العربي من
احتجاجات ضخمه ادت الى تغيير انظمه حكم
هذا الامر لم يحصل في فرنسا فحسب
حتى الولايات المتحده لم تتوقع هذه
التحركات الشعبيه في تونس او في بلدان
اخرى حيث كان هناك تظاهرات في اطار ما تم
تسميته بالربيع العربي في الواقع كنا نعلم
انه كان هناك عدم رضا وكانت فرنسا تتحاور
مع قاده الدول المعنيه من اجل تبديل
مواقفهم ولكن الصحيحه ايضا انه على مستوى
اندلاع هذه الاحتجاجات لم تتوقعه لاجهزه
المخابرات الفرنسيه ولا اجهزه المخابرات
الامريكيه ولكن هناك جزء مهم مرتبط بطبيعه
العلاقه التي كانت تجمع الدوله الفرنسيه
ببعض الانظمه القمريه كما كانت توصف في
العالم العربي رغم القيم الكبرى التي تقوم
عليها الجمهوريه الفرنسيه الم يكن هناك
تناقض باعتقاله
لا اعلم الى ماذا تلمح هناك مبدا فرنسي
معمول به هو عدم التدخل هذا لا يمنع حصول
مناقشه وربما تدخل من اجل الافراج عن بعض
الاشخاص او السجناء المحتجزين لاسباب
السياسيه فرنسا قد تفعلوا ذلك ولكن المبدا
هو مبدا ديغولي لانه ليس هناك تدخل في
شؤون الغير في بلد معاني ما لم يكن بطلب
من السلطات الشرعيه فيها